Okay.
Well good morning and we can get underway.
So far as you know,
we've dealt with two major epidemic diseases,
plague and small pox and we'll be examining quite a number of more beginning
next time with Asiatic cholera.
But our course,
as you remember,
I explained in the beginning isn't simply one epidemic disease after another.
There are also other themes that are very important to us.
One of those is already taking shape,
I hope,
uh,
in your minds and in your section discussions.
And that is the history of public health strategies.
That is ways in which society's organized to defend themselves against the
incursions that we're discussing.
And we've noted the first form of public health,
which consisted of those draconian plague measures and we'll see that they
aren't confined only to bubonic plague,
but there'll be cropping up again and again,
uh,
in the course of our our lectures.
And you've also seen that smallpox broad about a second major style of public
health and not as vaccination.
And clearly we'll be returning to that as well.
So public health is a major theme of our class.
And a third major theme is also crucial and that's the history of ideas and
especially medical ideas.
So we were examining one way of thinking about the course might be as an
examination of the career of what might be called scientific medicine from
humorless them through several subsequent incarnations down to the modern
biomedical paradigm.
In later weeks we'll be looking at the germ theory of disease at the debate
about contagion,
aneurysm and anti contagion ism.
We'll be looking at the idea of Sa Tropical medicine as a concept and its
implications.
But this morning I want to take another step by looking at a very crucial moment
in the development of modern medicine that took place,
this development between the French revolution and the middle of the 19th
century.
And it occurred in Paris and is universally known as the Paris School of
medicine.
This is a development that was so important that sometimes it's referred to
maybe just a shade glibly as the moment of transition from medieval medicine to
modernity.
So our plan this morning is to look at this,
um,
through first understanding major new developments that were a series of shocks
to the old humoral system of Hippocrates and Galen.
We'll see firstly,
some crises there.
The second thing we'll need to do is to look at positive precursors to the
developments of Paris.
As is so often the case,
it's misleading to think of the Paris school as suddenly appearing out of
nowhere.
It had its bases intellectually and institutionally in a series of prior
developments.
Those were preconditions that made it possible.
Then we'll look at what actually happened in Paris roughly in the period 1794 to
1848,
the establishment of a new concept,
a new embodiment of scientific medicine.
And the,
this is a step that laid the preconditions for the germ theory that came later
in the century for reasons we'll be discussing.
And then the last thing we'll do this morning is to look at the achievements,
but also the limitations of what happened in Paris.
Now in our career in scientific medicine,
we've noted the first embodiment in antiquity.
Uh,
we've talked a bit about Hippocrates and his establishment of the importance of
naturalistic causes of disease instead of magic explanations.
The rejection,
if you like,
of religious or demonic interpretations of disease and Hippocrates,
his hands disease was clearly a natural phenomenon with naturalistic causes.
We should remember that this had an importance for medical epistemology.
By epistemology,
I mean,
uh,
what do we know and how can we know it?
What are its,
what's the basis of knowledge?
What are its sources?
And we know that Hippocrates and his corpus of writings as stylish or embodied a
medical epistemology that held the knowledge in matters of healing is derived
from direct observation at the individual patient's bedside.
It's therefore often referred to as this first incarnation of a scientific
medicine as bedside medicine.
The locusts,
the source of knowledge is at the bedside through empirical observation.
We know too that this had as a corollary and educational program that how do you
learn medicine?
You do so by apprenticeship to doctors on their rounds to the domestic bedside
where the essential task was to observe.
Then we saw another development in scientific medicine and this was in the form
of Galen aneurysm.
This is to say that humor realism in Galen writings was primarily concerned with
the ancient texts,
texts that Galen considered essentially infallible.
They were to be enhanced and he thought that he was the person ideally suited to
do that work,
but they could never be overthrown.
There was no possibility of a conceptual paradigm shift or conceptual
revolution.
Okay.
This was what was called library medicine.
In other words,
for Galen,
there was a new understanding of medical epistemology.
Knowledge was derived from considering the ancients from a careful study of
their techs,
so it's textual lead based medicine,
and it had of course an educational corollary and indeed until 1794 in France
for example,
you call education consisted primarily of lectures on the classics delivered in
Lawton and have a program of reading the ancients in the original languages.
This was library Madison?
No,
the whole humeral system as we've been looking at it underwent a series of
shocks and intellectual criticisms.
It didn't seem to fit all of the evidence that emerged.
Let's look at a couple of these shocks to the humeral system.
One we've already mentioned,
and that was the great work of William Harvey and the circulation of the blood.
Now this meant Harvey's work,
uh,
although he didn't take the step of rejecting Galen aneurysm.
Nonetheless,
it's true that his work undermined,
uh,
gain Lynn's anatomy and it undermined humoral physiology.
So this was ultimately than Harvey's discoveries were incompatible with the
medical thinking,
uh,
of his time.
We've mentioned also that the chemical revolution,
the work of people like lawful ICA was extremely important and it was important
and undermining humoral alyssum because you know that the humoral a approach was
based on a theory of the four elements or the four humors.
Um,
essentially on Aristotelian,
uh,
natural philosophy.
Chemistry,
however,
undermined the humoral elements,
the four elements,
and began to replace them with a whole lead,
different,
uh,
set leading ultimately to the periodic table.
So the whole basis of the four elements comes to be undermined by the chemical
revolution.
And indeed there is a uh,
development of what's called [inaudible] chemistry,
which is the view that health is the balance of chemicals in the body and that
healing consists primarily of finding the right chemical to correct the
imbalance.
So medicine in this view becomes reduced more to chemistry.
An important figure in this is Paracelsus who lived from 1493 to 1541,
and was known as the Martin Luther of medicine,
a Swiss healer,
and to rebel against Galen aneurysm.
Indeed,
he burned.
He boasted that he himself had burned the masters texts.
He was a leading figure in the development of yachts,
row chemistry,
which was particularly strong in the low countries.
He introduced a number of chemicals to medical science such as zinc and Louden,
them,
uh,
or opium.
Another shock to the system,
of course,
was the spirit behind the scientific revolution.
The Scientific Revolution was empirical.
It was a democratic process and it rejected the cult of authority.
Authority could be challenged by anyone's observed observations and
measurements.
Okay.
And this was ultimately incompatible with Galen system of worship of the ancient
texts.
Then there was the experience that we've been looking at the last couple of
weeks of epidemic diseases.
Epidemic Diseases created problems for humoral interpretations.
How was it that so many people in a single place and time had this marked
imbalance in their humerus
and there came to be alongside the galenic system,
the idea of contagion instead,
which was a non humeral idea indeed off Frauca storto develop this uh,
strongly and it gained a wide purchase in popular culture.
And the search came to be for some agent responsible for epidemics,
not humors,
but perhaps it chemical.
Even some people postulated that it might be a living thing of some kind.
So all of these were severe criticisms for the humeral system.
But although Galen Ism then,
uh,
had these loose threads,
if we might say,
well,
this,
we have four 17,
94,
no consensus arose around an alternative to replace it.
We might make a distinction between medical science also and medical practice.
Uh,
that is the scientific basis of Galen aneurysm was eroding.
But,
uh,
until indeed the late 19th century medical practice,
what physicians actually did at the bedside remained traditional.
So we see critiques of Galen Ism abounding,
chipping away at its foundations,
but there was no new medical science that was robust enough to create a new
medical practice.
Note also that when we talk about coming of the Paris school,
something that we,
a couple of things that we won't be pointing to.
This new revolution in medicine that occurred in Paris was not based on some new
development in the natural sciences.
It wasn't based on a technological breakthrough.
It wasn't based on some pathbreaking medical or scientific discovery.
So let's look now with that as the background.
Uh,
this new incarnation of medical science,
the Paris School of medicine,
which was a conceptual revolution in the understanding of disease.
It marked to transformation in medical epistemology,
where is the source of medical knowledge and also in medical education.
And it led to a new position for the regular physician in society with new
claims to authority in competition with various competitors like homeopaths or
members of various medical sex.
This new medicine comes to be called hospital medicine.
And there are a number of classic studies if you want to read further about it
than I thought you'll be glad to know aren't on the reading list,
which I'm not extending.
Uh,
but there are places that on a purely voluntary basis,
I hope that you'll be going to read more about it.
One is the work of Irwin ackerk net,
who's one of the founders of the modern discipline of the history of medicine.
And he wrote a work medicine and the Paris hospital or there's um,
my colleague here at Yale,
John Harley Warner,
who's written against the spirit of system,
which is a study in particular of um,
American physicians and students and their experiences as they made a medical
and intellectual pilgrimage to Paris.
Or there's a famous book,
um,
by Michelle foo call called the birth of the clinic.
And I will wish you luck with that particular work.
It's one of the classic studies that everyone refers to with regard to the Paris
school and its importance.
But let me just tell you anecdotally that I've read it while I think four times.
The first time I read it in French.
And thought there was something wrong with my French.
So I read it in English and decided there was something also wrong with my
English.
Um,
and then my third and fourth times I think I decided maybe there was something
wrong with Fuko,
but I'll,
I'll leave that for you to judge and make your own decisions.
In any case,
it's one of the classics in the literature and it covers the ground we're
dealing with this morning.
Well,
what were the sources of this new medicine?
Uh,
first I would say there's an institutional basis that made it possible and that
is the hospital hospitals already existed but not as places of treatment so much
as safety nets or dumping grounds for the aged,
the incurable,
the orphaned,
the industrial revolution and urbanization,
however,
radically increased the numbers of patients and the hospitals were often
associated with philanthropy and the Church and powers the great center of
Western your urban center of culture and also became the locus for some of the
most famous hospitals in Europe,
the Otl Dhea,
the shot Italia,
and the PTA that we'll be seeing in a moment.
Um,
and so for a second,
and I think it's worth doing a little bit,
uh,
taking you for a moment on a bit of medical tourism.
Um,
and in doing so,
we'd go to the center of Paris here when we see the location of the hotel Dhea
hospital here in the middle of the sin on the yield Delacey tick.
The otl deer was perhaps the oldest hospital in the world.
It had a history of providing care on this very site ever since the seventh
century.
And it was the largest general hospital in Paris.
And as you can see,
it's located at the very center of the city.
This is its architectural plan.
It was a very large structure by the end of the old regime in France,
it had four great wards that could accommodate 4,000 patients,
often a sleeping several to a single bed.
We can see another picture of it.
This is a picture of the entrance to the church and the hospital,
uh,
taken an 1871 at the time of the Paris commune.
And we can see it's present day structure.
This is the great courtyard of the hotel Dhea.
And I'm pointing it out to us because it's impossible to understand the Paris
school of medicine and the new understanding of medical science without taking
into account the great hospitals of Paris that were it's site and were crucial
in the development of this.
It's ideas.
This is the Oto deloss shoddy tay,
another one of the great hospitals.
And this is,
uh,
the hospital of the PTA because Ip tit.
Um,
so the new plus battles become places of instruction under the control or
auspices of a centralized state.
There are large and have an enormous array of patients and the dire dedicated,
and this was crucial to furthering scientific knowledge.
Indeed,
they're more dedicated at this stage to furthering knowledge than to treating
people.
Then there,
if that's an institutional basis,
then the great hospitals,
they're also philosophical origins for the Paris school.
First is the enlightenment with it's questioning of authority.
It's skepticism,
it's empiricism.
And then I'd like to turn to John Locke in particular.
Okay.
Uh,
the great figure from 1632 to 1704 and his crucial work,
the essay concerning human understanding of 16,
19 which some people regard as so important that they place it at the very
beginning of the whole movement of the enlightenment will lock postulated as you
already know that the mind birth was a blank slate or Tabula Rasa
and his idea was what's called philosophic centralism.
That is that ideas and knowledge gained by the mind are not in nature but are
derived entirely from sense impressions and reflections on those impressions.
This is all
the cover of the essay concerning human understanding.
So we have in lock then a radical idea of epistemology,
the source of knowledge,
hence the word sensualism is the five senses,
uh,
used to conduct a rigorous examination of nature.
So lock also in his epistemology,
not only saw the source of knowledge but set rigorous limits to what we can
know,
putting God for example,
beyond the realm of knowledge and establishing rigorous steps for being certain
of the things that we can know.
Then there's another very important figure,
and this is someone we've also mentioned before,
uh,
who's becoming an old friend to us.
This is Thomas Synonym of the 17th century who wasn't fact,
a close friend of John Law and it's called variously the English apocrypha teas,
the father of English medicine.
Well,
pseudonym was politically a radical.
He was a puritan,
um,
uh,
a left wing Protestant who rebelled against the crown in the civil war in
England and served in fact as an officer and Cromwell's army.
He was also radical in his medical ideas.
His prescription for medical practice was rooted in the idea of centralism.
He called for a rigorous return to observation of the patient and he himself
called for the idea of abandoning theory and all preestablished medical systems.
The advance of medical knowledge would proceed by a systematic comparison of
case by case setting aside the classics and setting aside general system and
general theory,
oddly sitting them did not wholly reject humoral medicine,
but his ideas,
in fact,
we could say we're and his practice,
we're still influenced by Hippocrates.
But what he did was to suspend ideas of general theory.
And returned from the text to direct observation of the patient at the bedside.
In some sense he was skipping over Galen and returning to Hippocrates.
He believed that the physician should trust his own independent reasoning based
on experience.
He distrusted bookish learning and university education,
although he himself had attended Oxford and in return he was scorned by the
medical and academic elite of his day.
Pseudonym gave his attention also to epidemic diseases.
He studied smallpox,
malaria,
tuberculosis,
and syphilis.
Indeed,
he would be a good figure for talking about the impact that epidemic disease had
on the undermining of humor realism and the rise of a new scientific paradigm.
He's known also for his work on hysteria and on gout from which he himself was a
great sufferer.
Okay.
In his work on malaria,
he also did something roundup on nearly new or reaching the conclusion that he
was dealing not with the humeral imbalance in general,
but rather with a specific disease entity.
Indeed he thought he was one of the harbingers of the idea that diseases are all
specific entities rather than a single disclosure.
And he suggested that the time might come when they would be classified in the
manner of Linnaeus.
He even wrote all diseases ought to be reduced to certain determined kinds with
the same exactness as we see it done by botanic riders and their treatises on
plants.
Pseudonym also was a new and radical in sometimes embracing the idea of
contagion in his dealing with epidemic disease.
He wrote,
for example,
of the plug,
besides the constitution of the air,
there must be another previous circumstance to produce the plague,
namely the flew via or assignment minimum from an infected person,
either immediately by contact or immediately by some pestilential matter
conveyed from some other place.
So we see here erotically different idea.
Okay.
And he wrote a work of famous work of 1676 called the observer.
Nice.
Mady Chi,
uh,
revealing title,
stressing medical observation.
Okay.
So pseudonym is famous for introducing a number of practices into medicine as
well.
He popularized the use of Quinine for malaria.
He introduced opium into his practice.
He used calling drinks and fresh air to treat fevers rather than bloodletting.
And he introduced the cool regimen that we talked about for small pox.
Often he wrote the best advice she could give a physician was to do nothing at
all.
There was another important philosophical influence
and thoughts.
This man,
Pr Caba niece of French fellows off who lived from 1757 to 1805,
he was a physician,
a physiologist and medical philosopher.
He was also an administrator of the hospitals in Paris and an early supporter of
the French Revolution.
But the point I want to stress today was not in terms of medical philosophy.
He was essential list.
He believed that all mental processes are derived from the five senses.
And therefore in medicine,
the source of knowledge should not be ancient texts,
but direct observation of patients.
So that was these series than we've seen institutional foundations and
philosophical ones.
I now want to look at a third major,
a foundation for the um,
uh,
the coming of the power school.
And this is the French revolution itself.
Uh,
this is a famous painting of Eugen Dilla,
qua of liberty leading the people.
Um,
you got the idea,
what I want to stress is a general feature of the French Revolution.
That it was an opportunity to wipe the slate clean,
that it was marked around a core new departure that facilitated opposition to
older authorities and in specific,
uh,
nature to medical corporations.
It was also a time of French nationalism,
which urged on that instruction should take place no longer in Latin,
but in the vernacular that is in French.
There were also some other specific features that made the French revolution and
important moment for the development of a new medicine.
One was of course that this was a time of continuous warfare from 1792 for a
whole generation until 1815 and therefore there was an urgent practical need for
physicians and for adequate hospitals.
It was a time of reform in the structure of medicine as a career under
profession and also of medical training.
It was a time too during the French revolution when the hospitals were reformed,
centralized,
there was only one patient to a bed.
They were state owned and centralized and the wards became specialized and this
was crucial for the development of new medical ideas specialize according to the
type of patient being treated.
These hospitals were no longer devoted to hospice in orphanage care,
but rounder.
They became scientific institutions.
Patients were seen as having a service to perform and the name of science and
the advancement of knowledge their bodies were made radically accessible to
physicians and students both in life and very crucially also after death.
In terms of postmortem examinations alive,
the patient was a source of knowledge as physicians conducted physical
examinations to study the signs and symptoms of disease with rigor and precision
in death,
there are lesions were a source of knowledge to pathologists,
to surgeons who practice their techniques and to out of not a miss and
physiologists.
Well,
the reform of medical education meant that the locus of medicine was entirely
clinical and practical on hospital wards.
You were trained as a physician,
a medical student for three years,
followed by an internship and the faculty of Medicine in Paris.
Now consistent of full time professors appointed by competitive examination and
the French revolution was important for its values.
Stressing Ameritocracy by the encouragement of ability instead of privilege,
birth and cronyism and buy a new democratic spirit that provided a new dynamism
and a world of competition.
The new bounders inscribed the new motto of the medical profession were words
such as reform,
progress,
observation and precision.
Well,
what then those are the preconditions.
What was the substance of the Paris School of Medicine?
And here we see an extraordinary development where one city becomes the world's
center of a new medicine.
Powers was dubbed the Universal Faculty of Medicine.
It's students,
students and physicians came from all over the world to observe and to be
trained in Paris.
It's work was concentrated in the Latin quarter.
That became a sort of Mecca for scientists and students from everywhere.
Indeed,
large numbers of Americans made a pilgrimage to Paris to study with its masters,
to bring their ideas back to this country and to place themselves in a position
to raise their fees because of the prestige which went with the time spent on
the wards.
If Paris,
so in Marin medicine,
the rise of the Paris clinic was said to market trend time of transition between
the medical middle ages and then beginning of a modern era.
This was hospital medicine based on radical empiricism and oppose to abstract
theory.
The great motto in Paris was poorly in bulk,
who Voila a read little but see a lot.
The basis of knowledge was said to be facts grouped in two great facts with
linkages established by statistics and no room for obstructions apart from the
facts and their mathematical linking.
This was observation based medicine,
but it would went beyond the medicine of Hippocrates in that this is a picture
of Renee neck represented on a Paris Ward and what he's doing is conducting a
physical examination of the patient.
Lynette can fact were invented.
He was famous for his studies of masses of tubercular patients.
It's important to know that tuberculosis was rampant in 19th century Paris and
Renee.
Lynette had the opportunity to examine and treat thousands of patients with
tuberculosis,
which he himself contracted and he died from it in the end,
at a young age.
Well,
he invented,
and this was the point I wanted to stress at the moment,
the stuff,
the scope in 1816 so that the modern physical examination became uh,
more one,
not just observing the patient but examining him or her and the stuff.
Stethoscope scope became a homework and symbol of the Paris school.
Indeed,
uh,
it became a symbol in 19th century medicine.
Here we see this was the memorial stuff,
the scope of the type used by Lynette.
It may have been important also that he was a musician and specifically a
flutist and that may have influenced,
ah,
his method of proceeding.
This is the precursor of what is more familiar to us.
He introduced the procedures of Oscultation and percussion.
He tapped and listen to the internal sounds of the body and he described them,
uh,
the,
what he heard in the lungs of his tuberculosis patients as rails,
wrong key and all the other modern terms used to describe the sounds that he
heard.
Now this vast of patients on the wards was crucial.
A professor of medicine in Paris might examine some 5,000 patients a year and
crucially they produced a new concept of disease that is disease specificity.
Disease is were thought to be discrete entities that could be classified.
This is the beginning really of no zoology,
which is the classification of disease entities labeled variously tuberculosis,
smallpox,
etc. Rather than the humeral idea that there's just one disease,
the humeral imbalance or just crazy.
Now we have a linen type knows all logy or classification.
Okay.
On wards,
and this was very important.
Another innovation of the power school was not the symptoms on the observed on
the ward after the patient died,
if the patient died and very many did were correlated with the lesions in organs
and tissues scene in postmortem examination,
so an important part of Paris then was the linking of medicine with pathology.
Well,
physical examination with postmortem autopsies.
Okay.
Third developed came to be another word then associated with Paris,
a couple of words,
localism,
diseases at a particular location and the body solid disk which set them apart
from the fluids that where the humerus instead the location of diseases was in
solid organs and tissues.
Now the main diseases in Paris at the time were pulmonary TB,
pneumonia,
typhoid,
heart disease,
puerperal,
fever,
cholera.
Yeah.
With these discrete entities.
Now being classified,
we also see the rise of medical specialties.
So Paris was important and moving beyond the general practitioner to create
specialties of internal medicine,
psychiatry,
geriatric medicine,
pediatrics,
pathological anatomy,
veneer,
Realogy,
and there was a new notion of medical education that is lectures were still
given,
but the main place of learning was the hospital ward.
We're famous professors like Lundbeck himself or PR Louie conducted ground,
conducted their rounds with the red and you have hundreds.
Then there was the autopsy table in the hospital.
We're observation and ideas based on the ward or confirmed or not.
So the new medical education was practical instruction and it was hands on with
training on the ward from day one and the students who attended attended year
round with no vacation and there was a roll call for attendance.
Remember this was introduced at the time of the revolution and then under
Napoleon and under the empire professors even had ranks and wore uniforms.
So the practitioners work doctors.
But there were also,
there was an Neil licensing system and students were encouraged to learn through
their senses,
through seeing,
hearing,
and touching.
This was centralism not only in theory,
but we might call it applied sensualism with a rejection of dogma,
of theory and of authority.
Simply as authority
note too,
that there was not an integration into this of the basic sciences.
Uh,
this was medical science in a sense on its own without what we would now call
the,
they called the basic sciences accessory sciences.
Now,
the weak aspect of the Paris schools,
I'll was,
it's therapeutics.
This was a medical revolution in terms of medical science.
It was less revolutionary in terms of its therapeutics.
The new understanding of disease did not lead automatically to improve treatment
for the patient.
Indeed,
visitors from Britain and the United States often express severe moral
reservations about what they observed going on in the Paris clinics.
There was said to be little concern to alleviate suffering or to preserve life
knowledge and its advancement or what counted most the patient,
some visitors said was an object to be observed as in a natural history museum
more to serve science than to recover.
One American said in fact that a French version of uncle Tom's cabin ought to be
written about hospital patients on the wards of Paris and Eugen suit the Charles
Dickens of France who wrote the famous work the mysteries.
If Paris did a caricature of Pr Louis,
one of the heroes at the Paris school who appears his doctor goody farm and in
Dr Guinea Fall in the story tells his students on the ground on the rounds and
the ward of the hospital that the lesions that they're observing,
that is the symptoms they can soon look forward to seeing when the patient dies.
So could he phoned,
declares that a patient is a human sacrifice on the altar of science.
So the Paris clinic was also sometimes described by visitors as a theater with
patients as stage props.
And we're surgeons saw human bodies as a means to greater manual dexterity
physicians and their students.
We're not taught that their primary mission was to heal,
but rather to advance science treatment remained what it had been for a long
time therapy.
We can see one of the,
uh,
linchpins was still vena section war,
a bleeding by leeches.
And here we see a picture very widespread on the Paris wards where,
um,
hundreds of thousands of leaches were imported monthly by these hospitals.
Um,
and indeed they discover it also made it medical discovery.
How do you get a Leech to bite?
Uh,
well I can tell you the answer to that.
you,
what you can do is you can wrap the poor thing in a towel and soak the towel and
wine or vinegar,
which irritates it enormously and makes it by the next thing that it can reach.
So,
uh,
the therapeutics,
then we're a traditional and not different from what humeral physicians had been
doing for centuries.
The strengths of the Paris school,
we're in diagnosis,
pathology,
classification,
surgery and anatomy.
It's leading figures,
neck,
pure Louis,
pure carbon,
nice Claude Bernard,
but this stimulated imitation and other countries in England,
Saint Thomas Hospitals and guy's hospital in London,
in Austria,
the Vienna school of medicine was directly influenced by Paris and then the u s
of on our own country.
The linking of the Harvard medical school with mass general hospital was
directly based on the idea that had originated in Paris,
but by mid century,
the dynamism of Paris was on the wane and it had to do,
particularly with therapeutics,
there was a therapeutic pessimism.
All of the statistical methods of the Paris school revealed that standard
medical practices were of doubtful efficacy and tremendous advances in medical
knowledge had done little to advance therapeutics.
Medical Science and medical practice were quite distinct.
So it's in the second half of the 19th century that we'll be looking to yet very
soon,
another incarnation of scientific medicine when scientific medicine moves from
France to Germany and from the hospital ward to the university and to the
laboratory.
And then we'll see a new epistemology that stresses the laboratory bench as the
source of knowledge.
And we'll talk about the coming of laboratory medicine and experimental medicine
as a paradigm shift,
but all of that would not have been possible and we wouldn't have the coming of
the germ theory of disease if it hadn't been for the idea of specificity and
classification that were developed in Paris between 1794 and the middle of the
19th century.
And next time we'll turn to another epidemic disease.
And this is a timely one as we're moving into the 19th century,
and that is Asiatic cholera.